et on passe à la deuxième partie de
notre journal avec d'abord un phénomène
astronomique assez rare la planète
mercure qui s'interpose entre la terre
et le soleil
ce transit était observable partout sur
terre aujourd'hui à condition d'avoir un
télescope
ce qui est le cas évidemment du centre
sciences d'orléans une centaine de
personnes se sont rassemblées sur place
cet après midi pour profiter du
spectacle
c'est fascinant parce que ça permet de
voir mercure dans d une situation
particulière habituellement on observe
le ciel plutôt la nuit
or aujourd'hui on observe le ciel en
plein jour la planète
pourquoi partiel et elle passe devant le
soleil et pas sur le disque solaire qui
lui est bien sert d'écran derrière